He was vice president.
Kamala Harris is
scheduled to be meeting this morning
with Thailand's prime minister.
She's been in Bangkok
representing the U.S.
at the Asia-Pacific
Economic Cooperation Summit,
which just concluded
Chinese President
Xi Jinping is also there.
And on Saturday, the two spoke briefly.
Well, afterwards, the vice president
tweeted that during their exchange,
she reiterated the importance
of open communications
to manage competition
between the two countries.
Harris also condemned
North Korea's latest missile launch.
On Friday,
the young daughter of
North Korea's leader
made her first public appearance
during that launch.
These images appeared
to show them holding hands
as they inspect
a powerful
intercontinental ballistic missile.
CNN's Will Ripley has more
U.S.
Vice President Kamala Harris
and Chinese President
Xi Jinping
exchanged brief words
on the sidelines of the APEC
summit here in Bangkok,
talking about the importance
of avoiding conflict
and encouraging cooperation
on issues of global concern.
That's according to Chinese state media
as readout of the brief conversation.
One issue, though,
that the United States
and China are not really cooperating
on is the issue of North Korea,
which has been launching missiles
at an unprecedented pace
throughout the year,
including this ICBM
launch of what
North Korea calls
a new kind of long range missile
capable of striking,
according to the Japanese government,
pretty much anywhere
in the United States
and potentially most of the world,
excluding some portions of South America.
If you look at the possible
trajectory, distance of this missile
that was tested
and the missile test was pretty striking,
when you look at the photos
released by North Korean state
media on Saturday morning,
it was rising up of the over
the shoot on area of Pyongyang near
the Pyongyang International Airport.
Kim Jong un, the North Korean leader,
was there with his wife.
And for the first time,
his daughter, believed to be around
nine years old,
identified by North Korean state media
and appearing right alongside her dad
as they walked around.
This gigantic missile
dwarfed by the size of the
transporter erector launch vehicle
that was used to fire the missile.
Basically more than 3700 miles
or 6000 kilometers up into space
before a splashdown in the waters
near Japan.
Had the trajectory been different,
the missile could have traveled
much farther,
the Japanese government warns.
And yet
there has really been little
in terms of substantive consequences
this year
with all of these North Korean
missile launch events. At least 34.
If you look at the calendar
and some of those days, North Korea
launching multiple missiles at once.
North Korea claiming to have launched
around 50 ballistic missiles
so far this year.
That's more than any other year
in North Korean history.
And certainly it comes at a time
that there are growing concerns
about a seventh underground nuclear test.
And the fact of the matter is China,
which does have the ability
to heavily enforce sanctions
and put pressure on North Korea
from the perspective of the U.S.
and its allies, is simply not doing that.
China and Russia
with veto power at the United Nations
Security Council,
are basically saying
that all sides need to remain calm,
even though the U.S.
says it's North Korea
that continues to provoke the situation.
Will Ripley, CNN, Bangkok.